What's up bros!
OH, it's gaming time.
Resident Evil 2, that's right everybody, they made a remake out of this and it looks actually pretty good.
Usually remakes are pretty shit.
Actually, I take that back. I played this yesterday, and it crashed cause yo--
Okay, sorry, too many thoughts at the same time. Felix, think about what you're going to say.
Yesterday, I recorded this. You only get one chance to play this demo, for 30 minutes, so I recorded it and it crashed,
and the game was like ,"Oo uh sorry, we did a fuckie wuckie (??), ooh, ooh so sorry"
So I couldn't play it, so now here I am, playing it on a PlayStation, WHAT? Normies play on a PlayStation, I know, I know,
This is super embarrassing, like, honestly, uhhh,
But, here we go! Here we freaking go guys, I'm actually excited to play this,
To finally prove, once and for all, that I am, in fact, a gamer, and I'm playing a horror game
Smash like?
Pewdiepie plays horror game? I think that's pretty like-worthy.